- Hey everybody it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
and this is one of my favorite
formats of the content I do.
This is Pod Sessions, episode number 10.
This one's fun.
On a dinner that was done in, was that DC?
- August, mm-hmm.
- Yep.
- In DC in August, two of the
three wonderful individuals were here.
We were kind of shooting the shit.
I was getting to know one
a little bit better, one completely.
It was a format of a conference series
I was doing around the
country where I was speaking,
and then there was a
dinner series at night.
And they were there.
We were jamming, and it just
kind of like popped in my head.
And we were talking about
our third individual,
and I said, you know what?
Why don't we just all get
together and do a Pod Sessions
because I remember thinking wow.
A lot of this conversation,
a lot of what I thought
the third individual could
bring to the conversation
would make tremendous
content for the things
that I care about whether it's marketing
or actually building an actual
business or practicality
or siphoning from a
career to an entrepreneur.
Just a lot of themes, so I'm
super excited about this.
I've got a good sense of
where I wanna take it.
This one's a little more
under the radar Pod Sessions
meaning we've been bringing people
with huge audience and
things of that nature.
This is a little bit more of individuals
that I admire pieces of,
and I thought if we put it
all together we could
really make a nice meal.
So I'm excited.
Why don't we go around
and introduce ourselves?
And why don't we start to the left
and go into a kind of circle mode here.
So how are you young man?
- Sounds good.
- [Gary] Tell the Vayner
nation who you are.
- So, my name's Dylan Leazier.
I'm from Hagerstown Maryland,
small town in Maryland.
Most of you probably
never heard of it before.
Just recently moved to New York and--
- They've heard of that.
- Yeah, they have. (laughs)
And working for one of your
good friends Eytan Sugarman,
managing socials for
the Hunt and Fish Club
and for Southern Hospitality.
- And that's because
your background is also
in a little bit of that world right?
- Yeah, so for like the past two years
up until I moved to New York,
I was rebranding and
renovating my father's
restaurant and bar back home in Maryland
and ended up at that dinner with you.
And then things transpired
and took a leap of faith
and was like I'll move to
New York and take this step.
- Love it.
Let's keep going.
- Everybody, Rabiah Sutton,
what else am I saying?
I know. I forgot that fast.
I'm originally from DC.
Moved to Northern Virginia when I was ten.
Own a business called Forward
Think selling technology
services and products to
the government primarily.
- How long you been doing that?
- I've had my own company for eight years.
But I've been in the field for over 20.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Yep.
- [Gary] And how are you?
- I'm great, happy to be here.
- Sir?
- Steve Sheetz, from
Altoona, Pennsylvania.
Chairman now of the Sheetz Family Council.
I've been like bottle boy and dishwasher
and helped build this
business from one store
to 586 stores through the years.
- And for the people that
live in different parts
of the world, what are the stores?
- Good question, yes.
Like you, you've probably never seen one.
- [Gary] I haven't.
- So it's a convenience store.
We started out as a dairy store.
And then as times changed and people's
- Needs.
- demands for food changed,
- then we had to add gasoline in the 70s
when the blue laws went away.
We loved the blue laws,
Sheetz, because everybody
was closed Sundays except us.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- So everybody came to Sheetz.
So it was a dairy store with a big deli,
and then now we've really--
- And why were you able to, the blue laws,
'cause I know 'em because
of the liquor industry.
Why was Sheetz able to be open?
Because of the gasoline?
- Well because we had
less than 15 employees
at the time, per store.
In other words--
- Was that the essence of the blue laws?
- Yeah.
The essence of the blue laws
were different in different states, but--
- [Gary] Yeah, that's why--
- I think in Pennsylvania it
was you had to have like less
than ten or 15 employees, so there were
no supermarkets, no Walmarts.
It was all us.
So a Sunday was like
five, ten times normal day
because we're the only thing open.
We loved it.
And then the blue laws.
- And did you have
liquor license, too?
- We don't.
- Oh, yeah, that's right.
Pennsylvania state don't
controlled the purchase, right.
- Well right now, we just hit
a hundred stores with beer.
We've been fighting it since.
I came out of college in 1969.
We had three stores,
and we pushed for beer,
and we pushed for self serve gas.
We got self serve gas.
- Wait a minute.
This is a very important
part of the story.
- [Steve] Yep.
- You graduated college, you
said, or was it high school?
- Penn State, 1969.
- Right, so you graduated college the year
the New York Jets won the Super Bowl.
- [Steve] There you go.
- January 12th that
year, the New York Jets
changed the football landscape forever.
I love that.
- Joe Namath.
Some of my favorite Jets of
all time are Penn State alums.
Lance Mehl, one of my favorite favorites.
Anyway none the less, so, got it.
And so your parents started it?
- No, yeah, it's a long story,
but we came out of the dairy business.
My grandfather back in 1907.
My father then saw the
whole business changing.
He opened one store and then five
stores during World War II.
Then my brother came along.
Took over one.
So 1960, I went to work with him.
We had one store.
- With your brother?
- Yeah.
- And then he said, I went to school
to actually to be a math teacher.
- [Gary] You did?
- He said, come with me.
We're gonna open ten stores.
And so I went with him.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- We opened ten and he
said, let's open a hundred.
And we opened a hundred and he said,
I'm going to Florida.
And he left.
- Is that what happened?
(laughs)
- That was back in 1983,
and he's still there.
- And then you jumped in?
- And we still just send
him the checks down there.
He's happy.
- That's right.
So you jumped in in '83 to kind of--
- Yeah.
Well, yeah, I was really managing all,
but I learned that year the
difference, the next five years,
between a manager and a leader,
which I really didn't know.
But it was going to hit me hard.
- That was a super
interesting segue, right?
So this is something that I
talk to a lot of kids about,
transitioning from a doer to a
manager and then from manager
to being the last line of
the defense, the leader.
Here, a bunch of kids of are listening,
a bunch of people are listening,
but I have so many
young listeners as well.
I'm listening, and I'm saying,
you were in the business
every day for 14 years
presumably as minimally the number two,
probably closer to the one B.
And even though at that
age, on that transition,
going from either two or one B to one A,
there was a five year
learning curve in the way
that you put it on making
that transition from just
that small of a jump perceived.
But I know and you know is actually
the biggest jump of them all.
- That's correct.
- What was the biggest
shocking thing from being?
How would you consider yourself?
Do you consider you were a one B,
or do you consider you were the two?
Just something out of curiosity.
I'm sure it's just semantics.
- Well, yeah.
I would say one B.
- Cool.
- 'Cause I ran all of our operations.
- I would say so, too.
So what was the biggest
shock in that transition?
- Well, the biggest shock was
that I thought I was a good
manager, actually a great
manager, which meant that I took
this cookie cutter that we had developed
and opened the store.
- System.
- I knew how to hire people.
I knew how to do the architecture even.
I knew how to lay it out.
- I mean, you nailed it.
- [Steve] Everyday boom, boom.
- That's right.
To create that kind of
factory, to open those kind
of stores, people,
locations, that's a system.
- But the world around me was changing.
But as a manager, I
just kept putting those
cookie cutter out everyday.
But the world was changing,
and I wasn't changing with it.
You know, I was managing today's business
but wasn't thinking about
where we were headed
tomorrow.
- That's right.
- And we were in that.
We had to find our way
to make that transition.
And by the end of that five years,
I finally knew where
the hell we were going.
- And where was that?
- [Steve] We had to transition.
- Do you remember?
- Yeah, we had to go
from a take-home store
where people were making
sandwiches and eating at home
to a store where people
were eating on the run.
It was a grab and go.
But now we had 158 stores, and
we had to make a transition.
When we did the new model--
- You had to go from, for kids at home.
You had to go from being
more like a deli mentality
to a 7-Eleven of today mentality.
- Yeah, and with better
food, hopefully, yes.
- [Gary] Yes, of course.
- But absolutely.
(laughs)
- But by the way, that's
exactly right 'cause you had the
advantage of coming from
a better food place.
- But we had the talk
with customers to find out
where we were supposed
to go, and employees,
and then they told us.
So now we develop this
whole new model in 1988.
Now we had one store that fit
the vision of where we were headed.
- Which store was that?
- That was--
- [Gary] Do you remember?
- Well, it was store 158.
- It wasn't
the original store.
- Oh, I see what you did.
You didn't renovate.
- 158 in Louis Town.
- You made the next one.
- The next one.
It had everything the
customers told us they wanted.
- And how did it do?
- It did great, but now I had
157 I had to figure out what
the hell to do with those.
- Oh, shit.
Which is hard.
- And so we really slowed down.
To slow down expansion, it meant we
had to go back and reassess every store.
- [Gary] That's right.
- Could they fit that new vision?
- Did you sell off any stores?
- We did.
Very good question.
- Listen, I'm an operator.
- We had 15 in Pittsburgh that did not fit
where we were headed.
- Yeah.
- Very difficult to manage.
- We had 11 restaurants
that we had broken off into.
- Wow, wow.
- We sold those.
- Yeah.
- And we concentrated on
- You got focused.
- here is the vision.
- Impressive.
- This is where we're headed.
Now we've got to determine
which stores we can rebuild,
remodel, relocate, and that
was where we were headed.
- Good for you.
And so let's piggyback off this theme
that we're building on.
You made the transition
from doing what you do well
and you understood for
companies to then doing,
so many people listening right now,
they like to say they're entrepreneurs.
And they say that to me
'cause they're trying to act cool
'cause they think
entrepreneurship is cool.
And I'm always like, don't worry.
Being a great employee is a remarkable--
- [Rabiah] Absolutley.
- It's really funny.
I far more associate myself
with being self aware
than I do being an entrepreneur.
Like I would have been
pumped to be the number three
or the number 17 or to make
47,000 a year and work 41 hours
a week and have fun doing
all the other things.
I just want to be happy.
- [Rabiah] Right.
- What I ended up being
was an entrepreneur,
so I'm fascinated by a lot
of people who say they're
entrepreneurs, and entrepreneur
talk falls in to two things.
People who are scared
to make the leap into
entrepreneurship for a
million different reasons,
judgment, their cash,
they like their lifestyle
and they don't want to give
up some of the luxuries
for a year or two, and then other people
who are actually not anything
close to an entrepreneur.
It just makes them feel
better being an employee.
When did you know that?
Tell me the transition.
Give me the whole narrative
'cause I think you represent
something very important to my audience
and the world, and so I like you.
And I know you the most out of this table.
We've interacted here
and there a few times-
- [Rabiah] I like you, too.
- Thank you.
Did you from day one?
- [Rabiah] Yeah.
- You know, after you were
managing a whole bunch of stuff
and you were like, shit,
I don't need anybody else.
When the boss pissed you off?
Like what was it?
- Ah, yeah.
Yeah, so my parents were
both business owners.
My dad's a veterinarian.
He had a clinic my whole life.
My mom owned a children's book store
like from the end of elementary
school 'til high school.
- Right, so you were in it.
- [Rabiah] So I knew, yeah.
- Knew of it.
- Every weekend,
every all summer..
- Holidays?
- Yeah, we were with them.
- Easter break.
You're working.
- We're like, why can't we go
hang out with our damn friends?
Nope, you're coming with us.
So I went the trajectory
of, I'm gonna go to school.
And I was a average student.
I never really liked school.
The only classes I took
to were business classes
in high school, which I got
an A in and everything else
was like, if I get a C, I'm okay.
And there wasn't lot of
structure at home in terms
of like helping with homework
and things like that.
So we were kind of like, be
self motivated, and I was.
So I always had a job.
I was babysitting, selling
bracelets and stuff
at the county fair and things like that.
And then I went to school.
I always worked.
So retail, temporary work.
And when I was a freshman in college,
I got a job at a small
government contracting firm
and started answering phones part time.
And they liked my work.
They were wowed that I managed to like,
learn the switch board in
an hour when it was taking-
- You were smart.
- You know, the older
women like days, right?
- Look, look, look.
I grew up in my dad's liquor store.
Similar kind of background you know.
This company to me always, and
I'm sure you remember this.
There's no high for a manager or an owner
that's greater than
seeing somebody come in
at the entry level and be smart.
- [Rabiah] Get it.
- 'Cause you start dreaming
about their potential, right.
You're happy for them.
You're like oh, I just remember.
Shanika, Shanika Williams,
I remember at Wyatt library.
She was smart as shit.
I just remember looking at
her one day on the register.
I'm like, she won't be there long.
You know and like that's fun.
- Right.
- So nonetheless, I understand
that reaction from them.
- So my sophomore year,
I was working full time
and taking all my classes at night.
And by 21, I was making like
$40,000 without my degree yet.
- [Gary] Let's go.
- Yeah, and the money was good.
- And this is not yesterday so 40.
- Yeah.
- I'm just trying to--
- I'm 41.
- Yeah.
- This is 20 years ago.
- 40 is 80 just to tell ya, so keep going.
- Right, and so I worked my ass off,
but most of the companies I worked for,
the culture was not
where I needed it to be.
It didn't match my potential.
It didn't match the
things I was looking for.
So I never really lasted
anywhere more than three years.
The predominant wisdom,
still now, is like oh no.
You have to work somewhere
for a year or two years,
three years, five years, whatever.
- Don't screw up your resume.
- Yes.
- Such bullshit.
- You can't be job hopping.
And I'm like, no I'm good.
And then the other thing is
people are scared because like,
oh the grass is not gonna be
greener on the other side.
And it's like, is it really green now?
- You weren't scared though
because you had grown up with it.
- Yes
- Got it.
- And I just have a very
high risk tolerance-
- So was it from the get?
Back to my core question.
- Definitely no.
- Did you think even at 20,
even at 24 when your like,
oh wait a minute, this
might be the industry.
- [Rabiah] Yeah.
- I fuck with, like I'm into it.
- I'm gonna have my own thing.
- Definitely.
But I felt like I needed
some structure that these
businesses were gonna give me.
Obviously, in hindsight, I was like, no.
You should have started
this ten years ago.
- [Gary] Right.
- But it is what it is.
- [Gary] It is what it is.
- Yeah, and it gave me a good network.
- And so when did you do it?
- 33?
- [Gary] So eight years ago?
- Mmm-hmm.
- [Gary] Okay.
- It'll be my eight year
anniversary on the tenth.
- So what's the biggest things
that you're thinking about these days?
Like what do you care about?
- Scaling.
- [Gary] Scaling?
So what's going on?
- When I was so burnt
out just emotionally,
physically just from--
- [Gary] When?
- When I left in 2010.
- [Gary] Oh, right from the beginning.
- So I had gone back to
school in the middle of this
and got my MBA and just was in a culture.
This was a big company
now, and I loved the people
I supported locally, but
the people I reported into
in another state were just assholes.
I remember one day.
One of my bosses 'cause I had like five
in a five year period,
calls me into his office,
and he starts yelling at me.
I look around and I'm like, who
the fuck are you talking to?
My dad doesn't talk to me like that.
My husband doesn't talk to me like that.
You're not gonna talk to me like.
I'm gonna be in my office, and when you
can be professional, come see me.
And it just became this
really contentious thing,
and I was traveling a lot.
And my kids were young, and it sucked.
So when I left, I was just like focused on
making up my salary and like
spending time with my kids.
- [Gary] Right.
- And I feel like
I've been putting along.
- [Gary] How do I balance it?
Yep.
- Absolutely.
So for the first five years, (rings)
I was really just like, happy
to be able to pay my bills
and wasn't really worried.
- [Gary] See the kids.
- Yeah.
And in the last three, now
I'm like okay let's go.
My kids, my youngest is
15, Layla, and Joey's 16.
- [Gary] Big boys and girls now.
- Yes, and my husband is great,
and he's a better parent.
(laughs) so I leave them with him.
- [Gary] Yep.
- I've got a big family support
system, so yeah it works.
And now.
- You can double down.
- I feel like I've been, (tsks)
and now I'm ready to do this.
- And how many employees do you have?
- [Rabiah] 15.
- Yeah, it's a great time to scale.
- [Rabiah] Yeah.
- I love it.
Okay, let's keep going.
So back to transitions, which is
what we've been talking about.
You're in the midst of a
really interesting one.
I know you just filling
everybody who's listening.
You actually worked,
right, on a project right?
You were in school.
That's how you were, just give it to us.
- So I was in Steve's
entrepreneurship program.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Dylan] Called the
Sheetz Fellows Program.
It's like an entrepreneurial
leadership program.
- Under a different campus within
the Penn State eco system, right?
- [Dylan] Penn State Altoona.
- Yep.
- Yeah.
- And so you worked on it?
Oh, so it was his school?
- [Dylan] No.
- Like his framework.
His class.
- His program yeah.
- His program.
- Yeah.
- And so you went from that.
You told me about the
flipping with the apartments
and mom and like the video game stuff.
I'm just filling everybody in.
Then are you done with
school and you go home
to start rebranding and
like kinda marketing
and helping out with your dads thing?
- So I spent about five or six months,
and I worked under this
lady named Colleen Devorris.
- That's right. I remember.
- She helped with the Sheetz
rebranding in the early 2000s.
- That's right. That's
right. That's right.
- So I went, and I worked for her
for about five to six months like I said.
And it got to a point to
where I just wanted to take
the next step, grow as a person.
- And you went to work
for her from a branding,
marketing kind of stand point.
But it was more traditional,
and you were supposed
to bring some of the
social, digital aspects.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Good.
And you decide six months in.
Your like, you know what?
I'm gonna go do this, and execute this
against my dad's rebranding of his place.
- [Dylan] Yes, correct.
- And you did that for two years.
- [Dylan] Yeah.
- And so back to transitions.
You school.
You go work for somebody.
Then you transition to do
it for your family business
where I assume you had
a lot more autonomy.
- [Dylan] Mmm-hmm.
- How long have you been into
this hunt and fish project?
- This will be my third week.
- Right, so even in the
first 15, 17, 21 days,
what's the biggest transition
from doing it in a place
where you're like, oh fuck you Dad.
I'm doing this, to, oh shit.
I've got somebody who
isn't my Dad who I can
just yell at, or just take autonomy?
This is almost a reverse.
You're doing something super
interesting and thoughtful,
in my opinion, so I'm fascinated by it.
Everyone's talking about I
want to go do my own thing.
And not that it was your own thing,
but I'm sure that you have a
hell of a lot more autonomy.
You're now making the
decision of, wait a minute.
I want to go to, and I assume
you had maybe bigger leagues,
New York City, but not
having the autonomy.
You're going almost weirdly the reverse.
What's the first jump in the pool,
first three weeks kinda feeling?
Tell the truth.
- It's a little different.
- No it's important. It's important.
- 'Cause I won't let
Eytan fire you.
(laughs)
- And I want to bring value for everybody
who's watching and listening.
- It's different because there's a checks
and balances system now, right.
So you know learning to work--
- Right, when you screwed up before,
you could make pretend
there wasn't a screw up.
- [Dylan] Right.
- And just get away with
it in a family business.
- [Dylan] Yeah.
- But with this you can't do that.
- [Dylan] You can't.
- Yeah.
- [Dylan] Not at all.
- No but that's true right?
- Yeah, yeah it is true.
You know, you can kinda hide
behind the curtain when you're
kinda successful.
- And I'll tell it as a kid
who was in a family business
that had carte blanche.
I would always yell at my dad back
not about the micro loss,
which I had plenty of.
It was the macro win.
Anytime he'd be like, that, I didn't.
Why did we spend $4,000 on those coupons?
We didn't get anything.
I'm like, Dad, at the end of the year,
you are more than welcome to
kick me out of this place.
But let's look at it as a
whole not this week in May.
And the truth is, and I want
to give him a whole lot of credit.
He didn't have a whole lot of that energy.
It more of just the look
of like, you know like,
why did we waste money? (laughs)
You would have that in a family business.
Here, you've got a new boss.
You've gotta prove yourself, right?
- Mmm-hmm, 100%.
- And what are you most excited about
in the first three weeks?
- I think just being immersed
in a totally different type of culture.
New York city, you know.
- Sure, the speed.
- The speed, being around people who have,
a lifestyle that's kinda
like more than where I'm from
I guess you would say.
- Sure.
You mean the fellow employees
and the characters there.
- Just being connected.
- Spending money on dumb shit after hours.
- [Dylan] Yeah, yeah, 100%.
- I get it. I get it.
(laughs)
What is the calibration of
the New York speed so far?
Has it been super fast?
Are you addicted to it?
Is it like holy shit?
- I love it.
I love it.
I was always on the go back home, right,
and now, I'm on the go, but I'm
in the city, right?
- Right.
- It's not just like suburbs.
- You're running at the
same speed as the thing.
- [Dylan] Yeah, mmm-hmm.
- Let's go back around.
This is gona be a lot of fun.
I'm gonna take it into a
different place real quick,
and then we'll keep going.
I want to know what you're
obsessed with right now.
And I don't mean in the context
of everything we've just
talked about, like you're
pumped about some new Excel
formula that's helping you scare.
- [Rabiah] I'm not.
- I'm sure.
What are you just excited about
that's happening in culture
whether it's a TV show,
whether it's a new product
that you use in the bathroom,
whether it's an experience you had?
What I love is the zeitgeist.
What I loved, sir, listening to you talk,
I go, oh, I know why he was successful.
If you actually are consumer-centric,
you will always win.
The only reason I get to
sit here and people think,
I've got one pitch.
I always say I'm Mariano Rivera
I got one pitch.
I don't care about my feelings.
I'm pure humility to the end consumer.
I grew up with lemonade stands,
baseball card shows, and a liquor store.
I've been retail for my whole life.
All I know is watching the
eyes, watching the reactions,
using my intuition to what
felt good to the other person.
The market is my king, lord,
religion, nothing else.
So I always love this
question because I think
that's what I'm trying
to pay attention to.
Why are people wearing rips in their jeans
again like they were in the 80s?
Why are long hair back?
Haircuts, styles, foods,
like systems, all that stuff,
I love all that stuff.
So that's what I love, and
when you said I had to listen
to the customers and my employees,
you're absolutely right.
That's where all the answers are.
They're not in Bain and McKinsey's
fancy decks from Harvard.
They're in the trenches.
They always will be.
But on that same kick, the
reason I made that statement
was one, I wanted to pay you a compliment
because I really loved you saying that.
Two, it's about listening.
So what are you listening to
now, or what are you seeing?
What are you obsessed by?
Let's start with you.
What's the most
interesting thing going on?
- That's tough.
I think for me, it's just like,
not even to be selfish,
but my life right now
because everything in my life has changed
drastically in the past two months.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So just trying to get
acclimated to where I used to be
and where I'm at now and just being--
- Are you just enjoying it tremendously?
- Yeah, it's like I wake up every day.
I'm happy. I'm passionate.
- The action?
- Yes, 100%.
- I love it.
- I am obsessed with,
besides your content, is--
(laughs)
- Thank you.
- A form of intermittent
fasting called four, three
where you eat fours days a week
and fast three days a week for 36 hours.
- Okay so this is super
interesting because I don't know
what this is, but I'm
gonna keep asking you.
The reason, I apologize for jumping in,
is I'm actively fasting today for
this is the third week in a row.
I used to fast a lot, one day a week,
a couple years ago when
I really lost my weight.
It really worked.
The last couple years, the last 18 months,
I've been far more focused on
flexibility, soft tissue work,
a little muscle gain,
which has been amazing.
But I gained enough weight
where just, you know, I don't
care about the weight.
- You feel it.
- I just want to feel nice in my clothes.
I just want to feel great.
So I was like okay, if I could
just get seven to 11 off,
real fast, and the thing
that works for me is fasting.
But for me, I would fast for a full day,
which usually meant I wouldn't
eat for about 36 hours.
- [Rabiah] Yeah, 'cause
you include the sleep.
- But for three days a week?
Explain it to me real quick.
- So I do Sundays, Tuesdays, Thursdays.
- So Sunday you don't eat?
- So Saturday I stop.
- Night, you eat.
- 10 p.m. on Saturday.
- You eat for real.
- So Saturday I would eat for real.
I would stop eating at 10.
- By 10, okay.
- And Monday, so today,
I fasted yesterday.
Today, I would break my fast at 10 a.m.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So you have the sleep on both nights
As part of this.
- Yeah, yeah, interesting.
- And the reason why I did it, I was doing
the intermittent fasting
that everyone else
is doing for a while, which
was like the 16, eight
where you eat during an eight hour window,
so like 11 to whatever.
- That's like a fake fast.
I feel like you have to go past 20.
You have to go a full 24
hours for it to really matter
in my opinion.
- Well, I agree.
- Eight hour windows?
- And it's easier.
- That's just like normal life.
People eat too much.
- That's exactly right.
- By the way, when you
were in your career,
were you a eater during the day or no?
- During the day?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Yeah, but I could run it off.
- And you also had food all around you.
It's really funny like--
- You forget to eat.
- [Dylan] It's so hard.
- I have never until I,
actually what's really ironic?
Four years ago when I
started trying to lose weight
was the first time in my
life that I ever ate lunch.
- [Rabiah] That's what I'm saying.
- My big thing where I
was getting caught was
no breakfast, no lunch, but I would eat
like a machine at dinner,
and it would always be like 9 p.m.
And I would eat like 4,000 calories.
- [Steve] Yeah.
- My body, it's so easy for
me to fast if I can get over
the dinner hump because having breakfast
and lunch is not natural to me
'cause of retail.
- Right.
Yeah, so I think it's the same thing.
- How long you been doin' it?
- This is like my third
or fourth week maybe.
- You feel great right?
- I feel great, and I
don't mind the fasting.
- [Gary] I think it's great.
- I think the other thing is
with traveling like it's hard.
You can't prep, bah,
bah, bah, so I'm like,
no, this is so much
easier to implement for me
because I don't want to
be counting my calories.
I'm still tryin' to
eat well on those days.
- Who got you on?
A piece of content, a friend?
- So, yeah, a piece of content.
I don't know what.
- But something caught you.
- There's a lady named Sumaya
Kazi who was on The Today Show
or something, and they
interviewed her about this.
- [Gary] And boom.
- And she had like a
hundred dollar little plan
and I downloaded it
just to have something.
- Good for you.
I love it.
- To be accountable with.
- Sir?
- Yes?
- [Gary] What are you
obsessed with right now?
- Well, I'm obsessed with watching
the next generations of our business.
So when I started, we had eight employees.
Five of us were family members.
We had this business.
Today, we have 19,000 employees.
- With 18,000 family members?
(laughs)
- There's 101 descendants of our parents
or spouse.
- That's amazing, man.
- And there's 15 working,
so now I'm kinda the last
of the first generation
that were second and third.
And I'm watching this electric car coming.
And I'm watching our gas business.
And I'm looking at the future saying,
this gas business is slowly going away.
And what are these next
generations gonna do here
because they're dealing with
it right now on terms of--
- Do you think they have the
DNA that your dad and you
and your brother had where you
were willing to put yourself
out of business in the short term?
- I think we do.
You know that's our vision, to put Sheetz,
as we know it today, out of business.
That's our vision.
- Always.
- But I'm watching the next generation,
and I'm still there, so
I can feel it with them.
And I nudge them a little bit, you know.
- And how do they take the nudge?
Do they take it as Yoda,
as like wise old Yoda,
or do they take it as like,
get the fuck out of here.
(laughs)
You don't know what you're talking about?
- I think they tell me one thing.
- [Gary] They tell you Yoda.
- And they're really thinking,
get the fuck outta here.
I think that's what they're thinking.
- Who do you think you
have the most leverage with
of the family members internally,
and what's her or his position?
- Well, I don't know leverage with but--
- When I say leverage, I mean
there is that wisdom, respect,
and you can see she or he taking it.
- I'm starting to feel it
with the second and third
generation, and there are some
that are so damn sharp, it's unbelievable.
I knew they were sharp, but
do they have that feeling
that says, you know,
that competitive spirit
that says we gotta make it.
- They have a level of entitlement
that you and I didn't grow up with.
- [Steve] Absolutely.
- And that's not their fault.
It's their reality.
- But some of it's timing, too.
Some of them think they want to run away
from this gas business, you know.
And I'm like you can't run away from it.
When we sign this lease for
25 years, or whatever it is,
we're signing it based on
this gas volume and profits.
It's not going away tomorrow.
And then they say to me,
one of them said to me,
You know you've got your head in the sand.
I said, no, I don't have
my head in the sand.
I'm just trying to make sure
we get the timing right here
of transitioning without
gas at some point.
- You just said something
really, really important
that I'm gonna harp on
for everybody listening
who a lot of you are
trying to figure me out
and I keep saying, watch
what I do, not what I say.
And more importantly,
I do break this down,
but for some reason, people don't hear it.
I always talk about, a lot of
people want to give me credit
for predicting the future,
and I'm always like,
I'm not Nostradamus.
I don't predict.
I'm just good at what's already happened.
You're talking about
a very important thing
that you and I clearly share.
I had a funny feeling
just on the narrative
that we would have some
similarities, but as I'm listening,
it's maybe even further than I thought.
I'm humongous believer in not
overly respecting the past
but not being to ideological
about the future.
And I almost see everybody
caught in one of the two.
And I'm listening to you,
and I'm like, oh shit.
He's not.
He's more like me, which is,
he's not head in the sand,
loved what got him here.
I've just been listening to your words.
But in my business everyone's
like, Gary, VR, AR,
even voice that I'm very
passionate about with Alexa.
If you noticed, watch
what I do, not what I say,
I established it's coming.
But I've been unbelievably
quiet for the last six months,
mainly because the progress is slow,
and I'm not excited about it.
I couldn't agree more.
You have people come in.
And that's not what you're saying,
but for everybody listening,
I'm watching a lot of
people come into businesses,
whether kids or whether executives
and they want to make their mark.
And the way they think
they can make their mark
is by betting on the future
and then looking right.
The problem is, sometimes it
takes longer than you think.
The problem is, sometimes you
give up something that's valuable.
Yes, do I think electronic cars?
Sure, I also think self-driving cars
are gonna be a very important variable
because then you can make B2B deals,
not with individuals, if there's only
four companies that control all the cars.
They don't need the middle
man of the gas station.
It could be macro deals with
Exxon or Shell or whoever.
Nonetheless, we all know
those things are coming,
but I think what your experience
and my experience, look.
In 1998, when I took over
operations for my dad's business,
two years after I launched
Wine.Library.com, ecommerce,
I thought by the year 2000,
everybody's gonna be buying wine
from me on the internet,
and I've gotta go crazy.
Now, it worked out for me because
I was right about the macro.
So betting the farm with
frantic pace on the internet
was good, but if I was a
VC or had a big company,
not a small company
that didn't have money,
I would have definitely over-invested.
We just didn't have any money.
So I just invested what?
- [Rabiah] Yeah.
- You know, we didn't have a credit line.
We weren't funded.
We weren't a big company.
So if I was running
VaynerMedia as a 22-year-old,
I would have wasted a lot of money.
I just didn't have.
The luxury of not having is very powerful.
I think you are absolutely right.
Like plenty of cars are
going to go into gas stations
in four years, lots of them.
- [Steve] Absolutely.
- There's nothing that's happened yet
that would make me think
that's not the case.
- Yeah, if I did, I wouldn't be signing
20, 25 year leases because it's dependent.
- Yeah look, 20, 25
years, who knows right?
Like that's a ways, but to your point.
- [Steve] I agree.
- Start ripping out gas stations.
- [Steve] Yes.
- Would be insanity.
- [Steve] Yep, yep.
- I might, with you, if
we were like two people,
I'd be like, hey, do we want to completely
build a model 25 years
from today on gas stations?
That's an interesting debate.
- [Steve] Correct.
- Ripping out gas stations
would be insanity.
- And I think that you have to
look back at history as well.
The first 20 years we
spent without gasoline.
We didn't have gasoline.
Then all of a sudden, you build
this dependency on gasoline.
- [Gary] Well, of course.
- But you know, going forward we don't
have to be a gas station.
We have to look at our core competencies.
We can operate in six states.
We know how, obviously,
to create a culture
and an atmosphere where
people want to thrive.
You have to look at the core competencies
and say what else can we do?
You know we can run restaurants.
We can run car washes.
We can run one of the core competencies.
Think outside of the
convenience store business.
What else can we run?
- Or in the same way that
the biggest transition
the company ever really made was,
you know, you didn't go into
full detail, but there was
a transition at some point of
supplying dairy in one form
and then deciding to
be the retailer of it.
Right?
- [Steve] Exactly.
- Look, I mean, I think I
would argue that your company
has permission to be the transportation
infrastructure in some shape or form.
Your company absolutely could
have been the people that
invented the electronic scooters
that we see in California.
- [Steve] Sure.
- You could.
I mean, you absolutely could.
And I think Nintendo started
as a playing card company.
The biggest movies in Hollywood
are made from something
that started off as a comic book company.
Superhero movies, right?
So I do think when you take,
to your point, the energy,
it's about finding new containers
and merchandising them.
- Right.
And you know we go outside.
We spent three days in Seattle last month.
We got to visit Amazon.
We got to visit one of the
fulfillment centers.
- You got to see the stores
that don't have any cash.
Yeah I get it.
It's smart.
- We went into the store.
They're going to open
3,000 of 'em in the next
three years.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And who wants to go into a store
where you have to waste
four minutes for a cashier
when you can just grab and go.
- [Steve] Exactly.
- A hundred thousand percent.
- And we got to meet
with the innovation officer at Starbucks
who has 60 people working with her.
And so we're out there just kinda looking
and Carnegie Mellon we spent
three days with last month.
We're just constantly out there looking,
but I see that in the
next generation, too.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- Which I'm happy with you know.
- And so where are you
spending your physical time?
- Well, I've got the Sheetz Fellows,
so I teach 12 times a semester.
I mentor some of the students.
I got the Family Council.
We just met the other day.
You know, we study businesses
that failed as well as
those family businesses that survived.
And one of the biggest
reasons they fail is
that the family ceases to get along.
- [Gary] That's right.
- So we've got 101 family members.
15 work.
As you go in time, the bigger
percentage doesn't work
but owns stock, and they want to sell out.
I want cash.
And then you got this inner
group saying, that works there,
I want to hold on.
And that's the constant battle.
So as a Sheetz Family
Council and the head of it,
I'm trying to keep the family together.
So we do a retreat.
We get together Thanksgiving.
We get together Christmas.
And we're together all the
time, and I'm trying to hold
us together because for that family,
we want to be a privately
held family business.
That's why we work.
- Let me ask you a question.
- [Steve] Yep.
- You went through this
important transition
of five years, right, from going from
an operator to a leader right?
- [Steve] That's correct.
- I have to assume.
I don't know anything, and I already know
that you're a disproportionate
glue to this ambition.
I assume, you, at this point,
are giving a lot of thought
to who becomes the glue when
you decide not to be the glue.
Is that where your spending
a lot of time thinking, too?
- Well, some of it.
- And can multiple people be the glue?
'Cause I've been thinking
a lot about that, too.
- Well, you know, when my
brother was CEO, we had a rule.
We actually established that one person,
one family member, would be
the last one to say, yes.
One decision maker.
- [Gary] No two cooks
in the kitchen.
- He passed it to me.
- I believe in that.
- Then he passed it to my nephew.
But the next one came along and said,
I'm not sure I'm comfortable with that.
So now we have three.
It's me.
It's my two nephews.
There's three of us.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- So when I faze out, I faze out.
In two years, off of
kinda the Family Council,
the other two have to agree.
We have to agree on who this
third person is.
- Third.
Interesting.
- Yeah, so it was one, one,
one and the next one said,
I'm not comfortable with one
making all these decisions.
- [Gary] I understand. I understand.
- So there's three.
So now we'll decide which one's the next.
- What else is goin' on in your world?
What else do you want
entrepreneurs, executives,
other people to know, think,
or what questions do you have,
or what do we want to jam on?
So I'm focused, the
scaling part, on really,
we have been pivoting from
like, a peer consulting company
to where we supported a bunch
of technology companies privately.
We're trying to get into
the government business
as well as the Federal
government providing IT services.
And so now we're building
out this IT Plus model,
which we haven't finalized
yet, but basically building on
what you guys were just talking about.
This whole digital
transformation that every company
has to be really thinking about.
How do you do business, and how are you
using technology to
get that business done?
- Oh, my god, I always tell
people it's like electricity.
- [Rabiah] And they're failing.
- When electricity first came
around, there was businesses.
- [Rabiah] Yep.
- And if you were not a business
that's decided electricity
was a good idea, you
probably lost over time.
That was obvious 'cause it
was as extreme as like dark
and the sun went down and
your business had to close,
but I don't think people
understand how being fully digital,
like in your core, is a requirement.
- And an enabler of growth, right?
- [Gary] A hundred thousand percent.
- They're still looking
at IT is the call center.
That's the support mechanism.
- Defense versus offense.
- Right, absolutely, so we've
built a small development
factory where people can
outsource their development needs.
So if they have constraints
on the IT folks in house--
- [Gary] Can I ask you
a left field question?
- Yes.
- You know, we've talked
about this privately,
and I think you can bring
value to the people.
How much are you thinking about?
Being a successful entrepreneur
is an incredible accomplishment.
I think people think
you slap it on your bio.
You guys know my spiel.
I'm very worried that
people think it's easy.
- [Rabiah] No.
- And the internet has made
it easier, no question.
The cogs are so different, cost of goods,
like it doesn't cost a million bucks.
He had to build a fucking a store.
- [Rabiah] Right.
- Like you needed money
for the bricks and the wood
and whatever the first,
you still needed money.
There wasn't like, I'm gonna
be on Instagram all day
for a year and that's
gonna give me leverage
and I can actually on
spec print these T-shirts.
I'm gonna say I have the
T-shirts, but I don't.
I'm gonna take their money,
and then I'm gonna...
You can do things now.
I mean, I would've never
graduated high school.
(laughs)
But at the same token, that
entrepreneurship is on this pedestal.
What I am super passionate
about is what the internet
has done is we can now see
entrepreneurs in all shapes
and sizes, and you know how
passionate I am about that.
- [Rabiah] Yes.
- You are a successful,
female, minority entrepreneur.
You're also smart, so I want
to ask you this question
selfishly 'cause I'm curious
what's going through your mind.
Are you being affected by
knowing that you sit in a very
strong leverage point now as a individual,
and are you affected by
minority women DM-ing you
or emailing you if they
find out about you?
How much are you thinking about like, wow.
This is an interesting
era for what I'm doing.
A, I've gone through the
chapter of now doing it
successfully for a long
enough period of time
that even the toughest
filters would be like,
no, no you are one.
- [Rabiah] Yeah.
- Are you thinking about that?
And then, do you get into the world
of like, wait a minute.
All these years where it was potentially,
or not potentially, when
it was a disadvantage,
could I be going into an
era where it's an advantage?
How do I take advantage of that?
- [Rabiah] Right.
- How are you thinking
about this moment in time
that clearly must be interesting to see?
I'm seeing it through my eyes,
which are different than yours.
- [Rabiah] Right.
- What do you think about all that?
- So I think throughout my
life, I've always been like you,
I think like all, most
entrepreneurs, in this kind of
advisory position with my
family, with my friends, with
colleagues, and so I've one
a lot of counseling, a lot of
free shit from people for
years just because I could.
'Cause I feel like if I know
something, I'm not gonna
not tell you 'cause I'm
supposed to charge you for it.
I think right now, no.
My head is like, I'm 100% down
focused on like building this company.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- And whatever comes along
the way, I'm open to,
but I've never been focused on
what I look like or who I am.
I'm just like, no I'm
gonna fucking get it done.
- What about speaking and
books and being on CNBC like,
those are the things that
are gonna start populating
through your mind or brought to you?
- [Rabiah] Yeah.
- I'm bringing it to you right now.
- Yeah, I would be open to it.
It's not my focus right now, but I would.
I would totally be open to it.
- And you're aware
that that's in the air-ish?
- Yes.
- Cool.
What do you think?
how are you thinking about this?
Without saying, my master plan
is to work there for a year
and then bounce without
anybody getting mad.
Don't worry. I'll protect you.
Like how are you thinking
about this chapter?
Like let me go prove
it in the big leagues,
and then decide what I feel like?
- Yeah, that's pretty much my plan.
You know, I spent the past
two years really focused
on proof of concept, right.
Can I actually do something
and make it successful?
Not that my dads restaurant
wasn't successful.
- [Gary] No, I totally get it.
- But like, you know, build it
up 'cause we increased sales
by 40% in the past two years.
He's on track to make a million
this year, which he's never hit.
- That's a special number when you hit it.
- Yeah.
- 100%.
- That's one of his goals
that he's wanted to do
and to achieve, so like helping him--
- [Gary] So now you wanna see.
Can I do that again
but in a different way?
- Yeah, for somebody else.
- And then what do you intuitively,
like if you had a guess,
what then happens?
Do you build an agency
around that skill set
or do you actually build a restaurant,
hospitality business with
that being your secret sauce?
Do you know?
- Yeah, see I'm torn?
- [Gary] As you should be.
- I'm torn.
- [Gary] Those are two
smart things to debate.
- I grew up in the industry.
I know it.
It's second nature to me but--
- Which are by the way, I'm
sure that both of us will say,
even though you did this
from such a young age,
such a big advantage that
people run away from.
Like when you know something that cold,
it's a competitive advantage.
- Yeah, but also I know things
from a branding, marketing
perspective that can help, right.
- [Gary] Sure.
- Other businesses not
just only restaurants
or bars.
- I got it.
- So just trying to figure
out where I want to take it.
Right now, I got a group
of creatives, so we have
this little group, and we
do side projects right now.
- Yeah, that's right.
I remember you telling me over dinner.
You've got different creative
directors or a copywriter,
designer that you've
picked up along the way
and you got a little kinda
like freelance crew right?
- Yeah, so just like figuring out that
and then kinda being
the leader of the crew
and just doin',
- While you're holding
down a job
- Yeah.
that can be less flexibility.
- Yeah, so just learning
on the fly for real.
But I think for me right
now just solely focused on
helping Eytan improve
everything he has going on.
- What parting shots or questions
do we have as we wrap up here?
Sir?
- Well, I don't about parting shots.
It hit me though that in 1969
when I come out of college,
the first year we did a
million and then 1999,
and we did a billion, and then
this year we're over seven billion.
You know, when you look
back you say, wait a minute.
- By the way, just for everybody else,
a million in 1969 was like seven billion.
- [Rabiah] Right.
(laughs)
- No, it's really and privately held.
I mean that's just,
that's just remarkable.
- Yeah, and we've laid it out to be
a privately held family business.
As my brothers and I say, we're the last
of the first generation.
- Educate the kids at home.
We were talking about
top line revenue numbers.
- [Steve] Right, yes, top line revenue.
- So, for example VaynerMedia
this year and the VaynerX
family 'cause I own some publishing house,
I'm super proud that we'll be
close to two hundred million.
- [Steve] Correct.
- Yet, we made no money.
And I didn't lose money.
I don't have VC's.
I don't have credit.
I'm doing it because I'm reinvesting.
- [Steve] Absolutely.
- Talk to everybody at home.
You know, we heard the one million,
the billion, the seven billion.
For as much as you can remember and I have
a funny feeling you're going to remember.
Were you guys the kind of operators
and family that wanted
to always have profit?
In the lexicon of like, as
long as my salary's paid
and we can eat, put every
dollar back into business
'cause we can open up another store.
'Cause there's no way that
you got to this if you didn't,
in the early days, invest everything back.
- Yeah, see this is what
I tell the students.
I sat on the bank board
and on the loan committee,
and we learned to identify the people
who were running a lifestyle business.
They were in a lifestyle business.
They were not putting it in.
My brother did not increase
his lifestyle in those early days.
Even when we hit that million,
we were pushing vendors
to put in all the shelving for
free, to put in the equipment
for free.
- Maximize margins.
- We were pushing everybody.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And we were not buying
buildings or renting 'em
because our core competency
was running these stores,
not in real estate.
- Did you ever get
into real estate?
- Not, not in a big way.
- Not heavy in the scale.
- No.
- Compared to the scale that you are,
you guys understood your core competency.
- Yeah, we make money because
we know the damn business.
We don't know in real estate.
- Look, look.
Mister, I'll tell you.
I would argue that not pushing my dad,
my dad loved the thought of real estate.
And we spent way too much
money, building this superstore
in New Jersey that I
intuitively, but I wasn't strong
enough, so I don't wanna...
I should have pushed harder to say,
Dad, we're awesome at running
wine and liquor stores.
Forget about the ideology of owning,
of being your own landlord.
All that money that we
are about to tie up,
I could've opened up seven
goddamn stores and dominated.
- [Steve] Exactly.
- And you understood it.
- That's what we did.
That's what we did.
And the bank wouldn't give us money.
You talk about not making money.
We didn't make money.
- There's no VC's like me running
around writing dumb checks.
- [Steve] No.
- Money was tough.
- Money was so hard.
We pushed everybody.
- Back to my question.
Were the first 10, 15 years
unbelievably dollars back
into the system, and
was there a transition
where it became more about maybe
taking a little more profit
to appreciate some of
the fruits of the labor?
- The bank wanted us to
open one store a year.
We were hungry.
We wanted a store.
So, I mean, I just kept
asking, how do I get money?
And in 1972, I found out that they said,
pay your suppliers slower.
Pay 'em in 45 days.
We did, and we went from seven
to 14 stores in one year.
We almost didn't make it.
I mean, we were bending.
We were on bended knees for the bank.
And fortunately the banker
gave me money, gave us money.
Or we'd of been in trouble.
But we went from seven to 14,
really taught us a lesson.
We almost did not make it through there.
- [Gary] To number 15.
- But I always claim I got my master's
and my doctorate that
year from what we learned.
- [Gary] I get it.
- But we didn't have a lot of money.
- It's later on when we
start spending some money.
- Final thoughts?
- Thank you for having me.
No, this was great.
I appreciate it.
- I know you consume the content.
Anything lately that's caught
your eye or interesting?
I just love getting that perspective.
Listen to the consumer.
- So I was watching
a bunch of it last night in my room.
(laughs)
I think that something you guys
were talking about here were that--
- [Gary] Hit you.
- Yeah, is just like
the leadership aspect.
Most companies' leadership sucks.
- Because they're driven by money, or--
- Building their fiefdom.
- Yeah, 100%.
There's a difference between leadership...
Him and I and you have
the luxury right now
of being the last line of defense.
So there's a difference
between leadership and leaders.
Me, I am so different than
my nine sea suite executives.
You couldn't even compare us.
You know, not half of them, but like,
I watch them try to build up
moats, to protect themselves.
- [Rabiah] Right.
- And I have empathy for that.
It gets scary when you're a
top five, top ten employee.
You make a lot of money.
- [Rabiah] Right.
- Especially if you have me as a boss,
and I already have a funny feeling you,
if you actually like your
CO and you're doing well
and you like it, well, now
you're even double scared
to lose that job 'cause you're
like I could probably make
that money somewhere
else but not as happily.
So I've watched people around
me even be more aggressive
to protect themselves because
they're like, oh shit.
This is the golden goose.
This is money and nice.
Like, fuck, I don't want to lose this.
- [Rabiah] Right.
- But I have empathy for that.
And to your point,
leadership a lot of times
is different than the final leader.
And they often are
flawed because their job
is to keep everybody underneath
them to not take their spot.
- Right and I think most
cultures just don't do a good job
of figuring out how to navigate that.
So my husband's an educator
as a teacher and a principal,
and I always envied him because to him,
it was all about the kids.
Is it good for the kids?
If it's not good for
the kids then fuck you.
We're not doing it.
And I feel like in business--
- You have that.
It's actually, there is that.
- [Rabiah] There is that.
- It's called a customer.
- And you've talked
about it a lot, but I'm
saying, it's just not--
- It's not what most people do.
- No, it's not.
- But no question.
I'm sure of it.
- Oh, 100%.
- That's how they want it, the customer.
- [Rabiah] Absolutely.
- The customer doesn't give a shit
that you make all your
money on cows or oil.
- [Rabiah] Right.
- They're the customer.
- Right.
- There gonna live their
lives, and if you don't kill
yourself to win for them, it's game over.
- [Rabiah] Right.
- I don't' give a crap when
social media disappears.
Could care less.
Can't wait.
So that's been on your mind?
- Yes.
- Cool.
Final thoughts, brother?
- Just first, thank you
for everything you've done
for me from being in school
to here and coming here
and having this conversation.
Just thank you, like I
really do appreciate you.
And then two, I got a piece
of art for you back here.
- Oh, wow, that looks really nice.
- Yeah.
- Who made that?
- My buddy, Graffdummy.
- [Gary] Super nice.
- And then we did a
little video to that, too.
It's on my Instagram if
you want to check that out.
- Yes, I do.
- My man's video.
He did the video work.
- I'd be more
more than happy to look at it.
It's amazing.
- Yeah so we did something,
- It's super nice.
just based off your
clouds and dirt concept.
- Yeah I love it.
I can't wait to look at it.
Alright I will.
Everybody listening at home, I hope
you got value out of this.
If you're super bright, I think
you can make the connection
points that happened here.
I thought it was super rad.
I really enjoyed this.
I appreciate you three.
Thank you so much for coming in.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, you bet.
- Keep watching.
(light electronic music)